Hello, this is Dr. Cutters and in this section we're talking about the different brain cancers.
When your diagnosis cancer, it's very scary.
When we're talking about brain cancer, it is even more scary because usually what led
to the diagnosis was severe crippling headaches or a seizure or something and it's you feel
like you have to be hurt and done a pathway quite quickly and you don't get time to make decisions
quite often and usually the final diagnosis is it made until post surgery so then there
might be surgical post surgical complications that are involved as well.
From an alternative perspective, many of our brain cancer patients are doing standards
of care as well.
So there are a lot of different diagnoses in brain cancers, different types of brain cancers
basically based on the cell type like all cancers of the origination.
So whether it's a glioblastoma, astrocytoma, megaloblastoma, whatever it is, it has to do
with the cell type, where the cancer is located in the brain, what area of the brain that
it's attacking, what area of the brain is involved with the types of cells that's involved with.
Most of our patients, like I said, are doing or have done some standards of care and we're
coming alongside that to help support them, help support what their oncologist is doing.
Some of them exhausted that and now we're kind of solely primary helping support their body.
Always remember, even though you may have been given a grave diagnosis, there is always
hope, always hope beyond what was been told you or what you googled to just be careful
staying away from that.
Almost all the statistics out there on the specific type of cancers are doing our based upon
people who have done standards of care alone.
Well, be smarter than that, add some other things to your protocol that could help change
that outcome picture and you're going to be greatly pleased.
Most of the time, the choices that you have are not separate from alternative care.
So many people think, should I do alternative care or should I do regular conventional care
and you really don't need to make that decision.
You can do both together and most of the time that is maybe the better decision.
So when you add alternative care to the protocol that you're already doing, you can increase
your odds and increase the success rate.
Now when you decide to add some alternative care and changing diet and maybe adding some
supplements, it gets very confusing.
We realize that that's what we hear to help you navigate.
What supplements are right to take?
What you shouldn't take if you're doing chemotherapy or radiation.
What you should take to help decrease inflammation and different things is also a diet.
What other protocols could you add?
Maybe some technology that could be very successful.
There's a lot of data out there that if you do search for it, you can find.
We want to navigate it and get it as close to specific for you as possible and that's really
our ultimate goal.
Well, really our ultimate goal is that you get success in what you're doing.
Your quality of life goes up and your number of days of life go up because that's what
we ultimately want is for you to have success.
No matter what you do, no matter what you choose, understand that all of our information
on our website is free.
Download our books.
Feel free to utilize as much as you want if you never come to us.
That's okay.
We're here to be a blessing to you, though also that if you sign up in our newsletters and
such, we have your name and we will be praying for you and that's what our promise is.
We know that you have hope in God and whatever we can do to come beside that it helps support
you.
We want to be that for you.